el ministerio de defensa- azerbaiyán
hizo públicas estas imágenes
según bakú muestran ataques a
instalaciones armenias en nagorno
karabaj a una operación llamada venganza
desde el lado hacer y en respuesta al
intenso fuego armenio que mató a uno de
sus soldados cuyos elementos armados
ilegales armenios en el territorio de
azerbaiyán donde está desplegado
temporalmente el contingente ruso de
mantenimiento de la paz violaron
groseramente las cláusulas del acuerdo
del 10 de noviembre de 2020 y cometieron
un acto terrorista y de sabotaje contra
unidades del ejército a 0 y el 3 de
agosto pero en un comunicado el
ministerio de relaciones exteriores de
armenia pidió a la comunidad
internacional tomar medidas para detener
la violencia del ejército basir y que ha
lanzado varios ataques en los últimos
días para retomar zonas estratégicas de
la región el ministerio también insta al
cumplimiento de la declaración
trilateral lograda entre armenia
azerbaiyán y rusia
moscú acusó a bakú de violar el alto al
fuego concluido tras varias semanas de
guerra en 2020 este acuerdo ratificó las
conquistas azeríes y el despliegue de
una fuerza de paz rusa nagorno karabaj
desde la caída de la unión soviética
armenia y azerbaiyán se disputan este
enclave poblado mayoritariamente por
armenios pero históricamente bajo
control a cero a principios de la década
de 1990 una primera guerra entre las dos
antiguas repúblicas soviéticas produjo
más de 30.000 muertos